reunimos a siete actores de teatro soy
actor de teatro soy actriz de teatro y
actriz de teatro y un actor de teatro
soy actriz de teatro y actor de teatro
soy actriz de teatro
uno de ellos miente si el grupo descubre
quién es el mentiroso se repartirán el
premio en efectivo
si el mentiroso sobrevive él o ella se
ganará todo el premio quien es el
impostor
cuál es el papel de tus sueños el papel
de tu sueño para mí no sé cantar pero si
pudiera cantar me gustaría estar en
hairspray
la que canta que es una rubia hermosa
queen latifah la de la película me
gustaría hacer ella yo quisiera ser
eurídice en hey this town yo quiero ser
the wailers todos son muy buenos son
diseños quería ser el hombre pero yo
puedo hacerlo y hay de usted si
existiera una versión masculina de
macbook dentro del sueño de una noche de
verano sería mi sueño
veronica en header juro que seré evans
jensen quiero hacer drama genérico
dijiste genérico dije genético aliens en
eso con muy 2017 él estaba tratando de
acusarme a mí él estaba a la ofensiva es
lo más arriesgado que has hecho en la
casa antes de comenzar la función amigos
15 personas en el auditorio tanto el
equipo y yo comenzamos a recoger toda la
utilería y nos regañaron por eso lo mío
suele ser antes de cada presentación
justo cuando la audiencia está entrando
y las cortinas todavía están cerradas mi
compañero y yo nos vemos y bailamos para
ayudar al 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5
sí
él es demasiado extrovertido y creo que
se esfuerza demasiado él no hablaba
mucho no me da la vibra de un actor de
teatro
el cuerpo atlético era sospechoso dije
definitivamente hace algún deporte
[Música]
fue divertido gracias chicos
que tenías preparado para nosotros la
gente decisión de mí
cuando
ringo
gracias esta es la segunda ronda la
ronda de actuación cada uno tendrá 30
segundos para actuar delante de todos y
demostrar que realmente son actores de
teatro
[Música]
jejejeje
esto es muy extraño
[Risas]
[Música]
i
[Risas]
white
orio
y ella fue asombrosa canto muy bien pero
luego pensé que tal si solo fue eso
quizás solo canta bien
robert gates me y sin hogar
si a gardey en la fe
muévete
alguien puede pararse aquí necesito a
alguien de pie
genial
papá
la
sumisión y el
contacto
es mi obsesión
[Música]
y así de
pensé que fue demasiado exagerado para
hacer sólo una actuación de teatro
musical
sí
sí pero en un solo lugar pero luego
pensé tal vez es sólo una aprendiz
quizás es un técnico teatral
o
no
de las personas que cantaron creo que ya
hizo la canción menos convincente él
tiene buena voz pero como para cantar en
la ducha porque la proyección no se
sintió teatral
[Música]
[Aplausos]
louis lo siento mucho buscar una
merienda genial a partir de ahora cada
vez que voten por alguien que no sea el
impostor el dinero del premio se
reducirá a la mitad si todos están
seguros de que ya sacaron al impostor
pueden terminar el juego ahora pero si
la mayoría tiene dudas el juego
continuará por favor levanten la mano si
quieren seguir jugando
tengo una pregunta para ti dime cuántos
minutos tiene un año
525 mil seiscientos minutos en la ronda
de actuación alguien dijo que no le
gustaba tanto el canto soy una actriz de
teatro pero no hago música interpretar
papeles si también he sido director
escénica y para la que estamos
trabajando ahora voy a hacer la
directora del sitio voy a crear más que
todos utilería y con hecho teatro
durante ocho años pero luego como dos o
tres años atrás me transfer y para
probar más en la pantalla así que mi
ficha de presentación ahora es más como
actuación de cine hagan su mejor
presentación hola me llamo lauren
wheeler tengo 18 años mido 1.6 y soy de
sacramento hola mi nombre es allison
jimmy de 1.58 centímetros vivo en los
ángeles voy a leer para el papel de
vacío la me llamo cáliz othón tengo 16
años y actualmente vivo en carmel y les
voy a leer podemos movernos al
frente del escenario a la izquierda al
frente del escenario a la izquierda
no debería ser aquí porque esa de la
izquierda de la casa esa es la izquierda
para la casa y luego la izquierda del
escenario es nuestra izquierda no no eso
fue incómodo y ahora todos vayan al
fondo a la derecha
este es el lado
porque este es el escenario así que el
escenario es nuestro y la casa es de
ellos aprendes eso desde tu primera vez
aprendí eso y tuve que memorizarlo desde
el primer programa que hice que palabra
no puedes decir en el teatro scott
display es un nombre más
ni siquiera queremos decirlo a ti lo que
menos te gusta de estar en el teatro
muchas personas tienden a ser presumida
o el drama en el drama sí creo que antes
del casting como cuando el director hace
un programa y ya lo tienes no lo dicen
esto va para aire y lo he visto va a ir
al senior
si trabajas en el escenario y eres
directora deberías saber cuál es la
izquierda o derecha de la casa
pareciera que quiere pasar por
desapercibida
ella me parece muy sospechosa
si lo sabía
por favor levanten la mano si desean
continuar el juego
si la luz cambia a verde significa que
eliminaron al impostor y ganaron si la
luz cambia a rojo significa que el
impostor sigue adentro y perdieron
jamás y nunca no lo podía creer y luego
pensé oh es austin es austin puede dar
un paso al frente para revelarse el
impostor interés
[Música]
ahora no puedo comprar
hasta te dije que tus arcilloso bueno mi
mejor amigo es técnico de teatro me robe
sus respuestas además mis otros amigos
están en el teatro y me la paso con
ellos y me cuentan todo sobre esto tú te
equivocaste en el escenario gracias a mi
ganas del dinero de nada por eso jamás
sospeche de ti para nada escribí mis
notas estás a salvo
el tema
e
[Música]